okay let's play another game I'm trying
to raise my rating and also satisfy
opening recommendations this can be a
slightly dangerous combination
Icelandic gambit only when tog II is
here while I play the Icelandic rat
defense wait what - I plugins t4 anyone
recommend a d4 opening I'll play I'll
play knife six England Buddha okay I'll
play budapest why not playing South
African wolf hey Z bit 31 thanks for
subbing okay Budapest time own ID for
opponent seems prepared play this move
let's move knight c6
maybe Queen h4 it's questionable
what's interesting ok the Queen's
attacking the knight so I think my
opponent overlooked this but can i
exploit it take
I'll say couldn't rights I could take
the bishop with check I have to and then
take here I just went up on theirs Queen
d5 attacking this in this but then I
have Queen e7 I take with check it's
also kind of interesting
Queenie sevens the safest maybe I'll
work lift threatening to take with check
yeah let's rock lift probably rookie
sixes idea I want to bring the rook in
play b6 and then someday this well I
have rook rook d6 here looks fun I'm
just simplifying takes takes takes takes
way free Queen I like free Queens
it's nice when the opponent plays a boat
as gambit very nice okay kind of a messy
game rematch the e4 this game I wanted a
Spanish now we have a French I'll play
the b3 line I played this yesterday was
a nice game g4g five ideas I shipped you
to play h3 for good measure defending
before I capture now I'll take okay have
a fight Queen f6 wants to meet me defend
every night ft3 the spawn is kind of
tender
I can take twice I believe this takes
takes takes and then takes I take three
times
oh but at seven F choose hanging but it
doesn't matter
after choose defended and D for ideas
yeah life is very good a nice opening
castling so i have sony discoveries i
have this move Knight c4 also a move d4
whoa Nikola is back it's so much Nikola
some nice milestone I have a lot of
options here
I'd c4 seems most natural d4 at 93
I shouldn't take too long I'm just
weighing my options I think I'll play
this move Queen h4 surprise maybe I'll
just castle because the bishops now
stare down the King for a key eight
Bishop h7 I can play f4 now
I take the night now let's do this
if Rukia I can take the nights so I
attack the Queen and it's very important
I take the rook with check otherwise
Queen anyone mate ninety five looks nice
Queens almost trapped I could vote s
gambits play this move I just have to
move quicker interesting position though
I want to take my time twenty four way
this move getting out of the pin
defending the pawn also attacking the
knight twice so I'm also attacking the
bishop should fear my arrows defends
everything and this move keep the bishop
like a soccer ball whoa this move okay
boat s gambit I'm part seven or part six
although this is so beautiful
this is so beautiful oh but is it
beautiful Bishop b4 aha this is so
beautiful look at this I was so
beautiful just beauty out of nowhere
boat s gambits the only time I play this
b3 French line it's always a boat s
gambit well that's going on YouTube
YouTube people hope you enjoyed that you
can check out botas i'll leave links in
the video description she has a
Wikipedia page